good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday it is a
gloomy Thursday here in New York City
but hey Claude hiya dirt
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast I am doing good it is
you know I haven't stepped outside or
even opened my window so I don't know
what kind of day it is in New York but I
just know I'll be staying inside
therefore it's not important what it is
going on outside it's actually this is
beautiful quarantine weather because
it's nothing that tempts you to want to
leave your house and so when I woke up
this morning I could see through the
shade said it was a little gloomy I got
sort of calm but I had to like wrack my
brain and make sure I didn't have plans
leave the house today which I don't and
I'm stoked
actually you're coming over later so oh
yeah thanks for this later the whole
weather could change by then um so funny
I was having this conversation with Ben
last night um cuz like in the beginning
of quarantine like it was unfathomable
that we wouldn't be able to leave our
houses for so long and now that we've
been in it for a while I honestly like
can't imagine life not in quarantine and
like we just started phase one in New
York so I know that it is going to
eventually come to an end like there's
light at the end of the tunnel
but I'm like kind of sad about it like I
don't want to leave no now that there's
light at the end of the tunnel I'm sort
of cherishing these last few weeks in
the queue so I do I feel you on that but
I'm excited for our plans tonight
that'll be really fun we're having
little and I we're doing a blog G and
I'm making a pizza drinking wine playing
games just having fun maker patreon in
for ourselves because we really need one
we deserve it we deserve each other
this had and you oh you don't [ __ ]
know that's on I'm always singing this
song from wicked you're both so smart oh
no I only know it's about a hat it's
about a hat is it about misses huh yes
and mr. hat it's such a good song I mean
it's only one part of the song that's
dedicated to the Hat and it because you
should wear this hat to the party
tonight
don't you think and I'm always telling
you guys to wear this hat so party
mate and you guys never know what I'm
talking so but some some Broadway
Steen's are gonna know what I'm talking
about and this one's for you well we
have a great show we are not recapping
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills because
much to my chagrin
it wasn't on last night and New York is
not on tonight either like they're on
hiatus till July I don't know okay I
mean I was bummed about Beverly Hills
but I can't say I'm so bummed about New
York like that means that more time for
me watching Potomac seeing the ladies go
to Bermuda I'm so excited I ended like
right I'm the episode right before
they're going on a trip so I just have
the world is my oyster like I'm going to
Bermuda today I don't know about you
gotta get your mutants we're being like
super musical this week and I think that
it's for the best you know it's so funny
I was on the phone with Taylor's trekker
last night and I realized like I was
doing this thing that I used to do when
I came every summer like when I was in
high school when I would come back from
camp
I like picked up on annoying habits like
my bunkmates we're doing and when I was
a super senior like all the girls on my
bunk just like saying they were like
pass the towel and I came home and I was
doing it and like my friends thought it
was so annoying like my school friends
and now I find myself doing that all the
time I'm like this is incredible that's
what you embed you all the time
everywhere that's like who in Ben thing
a hundred percent and then also what you
guys do is like you constantly we all do
this but you guys he get to another
level where you like you're like oh this
is sad chair it's a ser oh yeah I mean I
can't there are over a million words in
the English language and honestly like
that's too many sometimes you just need
to combine words you know like uh
dish issues you have a dish dish issues
no you have dishes like combining what's
called conjunction contraction right
contraction is when you don't you know
mansion what's your song it's like
sensual for it's like a hit song to like
learn about and
and my grammar no section it's like I
could see louanddan like a dirty cabaret
bar downtown me like conjunction
junction what's your function
I completely agree okay so it's the act
of contraction though is the atom
decreasing something in size or volume
or quantity or scope so it's being
contracted into one word therefore it is
a contraction
okay well everyone should do it more
because I'll or you know it's a sad
chair
it's there yeah good times
these are wine curtains Wharton's yeah
no you guys just do it with everything
and that's just what you do that cool
girl I bought you that's okay guess in
the whole day through show you buttons
it's true that's what girls do yes what
movie is that from something stellar
from the 90s that legendre of like
female band 90s movie music like I wanna
reach out better I'm gonna make a ring
I'm gonna fly like a bird and spread my
wings come on come on
anything like that play that at my
funeral please okay hundred percent when
they're bringing in the casket like I
want all the pole bearers you have
everybody that the pallbearers will like
arrange a harmony so it's gonna be like
maybe I'm around right there like she's
I mean it's gonna be tasteful obviously
yeah don't worry I'll um I'll oversee
the musical she'll be the funeral
department yes exactly can we cool well
um we have a great show for you today as
Claudia had said speaking about the
great show's new episode of the redheads
is up we are recapping code-named
Halloween which has I think the I think
is my favorite book we've ever read in
the redhead
I'm gonna go ahead and say it I loved it
it's a true story of a fabulous
incredible woman I know we hate the word
like boss [ __ ] but um she was
everything of the sort in that way and
we are self-hating boss [ __ ] like a
hundred percent you could call us boss
[ __ ] like we are bosses and we are
[ __ ]
but please don't play you could but
don't but no she's an amazing French
woman who was a member of the French
Resistance like spying and really helped
win the war in World War two it's it's
amazing story so um if you if you were
on the fence about reading it definitely
read it listen to the episode and now
I'm so excited to read our next book
which is I Know Why the Caged Bird Sings
by Maya Angelou so I hope you guys enjoy
the episode if you're partaking this not
but I recommend that you partake if you
ever sometimes partake in redheads
partaking is it's particularly
interesting yeah I do love to partake
okay should we dive right in
yeah I'm off the deep end watches a
Devin to the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
oh yes Jackie that is true but you know
I'm beginning I'm actually so many dm's
about people being like what was that
company that you guys talked about on
the toast that takes like your photos
and your old home videos and digitizes
them for you and with Father's Day
coming up it is the perfect time to talk
about legacy box a very simple mailing
service to have all your video tapes
camcorder tapes film meals and pictures
digitally preserved on the thumb drive
DVD or in the cloud if you have some of
your favorite memories with your dad for
Father's Day coming up like him teach
you how to ride a bike father-daughter
dance at your wedding um make sure you
can get your legacy box for your dad
because that's like such a good gift for
dads
od legacy bow box helps bring new life
into your old media by unlocking those
trapped family memories and putting them
on a monitor and digital format that's
easy to use it's ensuring that your
family's legacy is digitally preserved
so it can be passed down which is just
as important as creating those memories
legacy box is weight is a way for you to
easily and affordably digitally preserve
your past the process from start to
finish is super easy you pack in
send all your materials their team
digitizes everything by hand and then
you enjoy get back perfectly preserved
digital copies on the thumb drive DVD or
the cloud ready to watch share and enjoy
plus they keep you up to date with
regular email updates throughout the
process
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizer of home videos and photos and
has helped over 750 thousand families
digitally preserve the past rediscover
your glory days by digitizing these
irreplaceable heirlooms with legacy box
when the favorite kit award is Father's
Day and give dad a present he'll never
forget it gets started preserving your
family's legacy go-to legacy box comm
slash toast to get an incredible 50
percent off your first order buy today
and take advantage of this exclusive
offer send in when you're ready legacy
box is great for you or someone you love
go to legacy box.com slash toasts to
save 50% off while supplies last so like
we said a great gift for Father's Day
which is coming up and if you are lucky
enough to have a dad you might really
like this yes sign on get a great gift
for Father's Day or sign on and get your
memories right or get it for yourself a
hundred per cell like this is a gift but
it's also an essential you know it's one
of those things like you get for someone
but you know like you're gonna be the
one using it ya know it's like everyone
should have one so yes it's a gift but
I'm just getting you something you
should have yeah you know okay
first story piggybacking off of the big
news from yesterday but Lisa Vanderpump
is speaking out after for Vanderpump
rules stars were fired she said quote I
condemn all forms of racism quote this
is from her statement over the past two
weeks many things have been brought to
my attention of which I and many others
were previously unaware it was necessary
for me to be quiet
until now until decisions had been made
now I can speak freely from the heart
she said she referenced the recent
tragedies in the world including the
death of George Floyd while in police
custody and the corona virus pandemic
she said as we've seen such devastating
sadness that has played out globally we
all have a part to play to create a
kinder more just society my hope is for
this generation to treat each other with
respect and humanity and realized that
actions have and should have
consequences she talks a little bit
about her business and how I think she's
addressing some of these claims that you
know the show is not diverse at all and
she says that she has a lot of
different people from different
backgrounds that work in her restaurants
but the show focuses on this one group
of friends okay but that's not what we
asked we don't we I know that your
restaurants are quote unquote diverse
I'm honestly like this is a nice
statement but I feel like it totally
missed the mark on what people are upset
with her about and that is one the lack
of diversity on the show and to some of
the claims that faith had to say about
Lisa Vanderpump she had choice words for
Lisa and said that at one point Lisa
told her to act like NeNe Leakes yeah so
she did not address she did not address
that she just sort of discussed what's
got been going on in her show and in her
world and and in the world in general I
think generally speaking it was um it
was it was a very warm statement um
she's not dragging any of the people who
used to work for her but she's also not
condoning what they did in any way shape
or form
yeah I mean to be honest like this
statement was I didn't learn anything
new and it definitely felt like she had
to say something because there's so much
conversation being had like around her
show and her restaurants but I don't
really feel I could accomplish anything
it really gave me any answers in terms
of Lisa's involvement it just seemed
like she kind of took herself out of the
equation I think that she's not in the
equation I know I mean but she is we've
had something to say about her yeah and
also she is in the equation like when
she wants someone to be fired but I
guess Kristin and saucy never worked at
her restaurants but she fired James when
she thought that he needed to be fired
so she does have the power over her
restaurants but not over the show I
think that she definitely has power over
the restaurants I do think she has a lot
to say I think like her voice is is
heard when it comes to casting hiring
firing on the show I definitely think
she has input I'm not sure I'm not
totally convinced it would make sense if
she did but I could also see how she
might not
additionally Andy Cohen broke his
silence on Stassi and Kristen being
fired he said quote there's so much
happening in the Bravo universe I will
say this there's so much to talk about
Vanderpump rules and then of course the
reunion ended up airing last night he
said this on his radio show he said I
will say this about what happened I
absolutely support Bravo's decision I
think it was the right decision and I
want to remind people because I've been
getting so many tweets and messages and
whatever
Vanderpump rules in southern charm and
other shows I am NOT I don't I feel like
I have to remind people this all the
time I'm not in charge of programming at
Bravo anymore I am NOT an executive
producer of Vanderpump rules I don't
have anything to do with the show except
I love it and I host the reunions I
don't produce the show so what I want
people to know is I have no say in
hiring and firing I had completely
forgotten that like I just associate
Broadway with Andy and like that he is
the head of Bravo and he's told us so
many times that he is no longer but
that's just like it doesn't make sense
to me so I refuse to acknowledge it yeah
and sometimes like even if it's not a
Housewives show like I know he swaps his
name on as an executive producer which i
think is just a part of his deal with
his production company and Bravo but I
do think that was important for people
to remind him because Bravo fans
especially like the crazy ones on
Twitter like they take their pitchforks
to Andy's profile when they're unhappy
about something while at the end of the
day like he's actually not the person
making these decisions so I think it was
very important for people to for him to
remind people of that yeah I needed to
be reminded for sure because when I
think about Bravo making decisions about
Stassi and Kristen like I think Andy's
in the room and he but does Andy like
them what does Andy think and it really
has no Andy his talent just like them
yeah and you just I think that part of
the confusion comes from like him also
being the host of watch rappin side like
he doesn't only have the housewives on
watch Rabin's IPS southern charm he has
better promise rules so it is confusing
and I and I see why people think of him
as like the punching bag
no but it's also like he does the
reunions like and he started hosting
watch what happens live because he was
the executive producer Bravo and the
head man in charge is gonna talk to all
the people on TV shows it was like a
genius idea along the way he stopped
being the head man in charge and we just
like got the memo but chose not to read
it ya know cuz it's like business stuff
it's in his book a lot too because his
book is like basically journal entries
and he journals around the time where he
gets this huge deal with Bravo where
basically um Andy runs uh most talkative
production companies which is a
production company that puts on a lot of
the Bravo stuff and so he now I think
works at the production company but the
production company has an overall deal
with Bravo so he's still very much
connected to Bravo but he's in his
office he's not in 30 rock anymore yeah
it's
it's it's so thank you sunny to be it's
so B to be you know internal thing it's
a need-to-know thing yeah but I guess
now we needed to know and he is sharing
that information with us well then that
sucks because he's getting the brunt of
like everyone's frustrations like on
social media when he's actually not the
man who makes the decisions yeah
interesting interesting I see you're
changing your sheets back there how's
that going yes you know I'm part of
being the host of this show and coming
on here every day is like people know
when like the frequency at which I
change my sheets so normally I would go
like three weeks but I've been really
good like on a week-to-week basis that's
really good but you could always say
like you change him in the afternoon
like you wanted this bed to be made for
the show and then you were gonna you
know like you could lie to us if you
needed to yeah I could but you know what
like once I start lying at least for me
it's just like a slippery slope to like
lying to everyone about everything and I
don't want to like start the trend of
like lying to the fans on the show you
know yeah I feel that I did my sheets
yesterday and it was it was nice it was
it was nice I mean there's literally
nothing better than a fresh sheet it's
true last night I slept quite well not
gonna my god I was tossing and turning
all [ __ ] night it was the worst
night's sleep like I I don't know what's
wrong with me but like I've been up all
night like thinking but I'm asleep does
that make sense yeah that doesn't make
sense
I wonder what actually turn my brain off
yeah maybe you need to drink more water
maybe you're dehydrated I sleep like
that when I'm dehydrated oh that's
interesting I mean I have um because I
sleep like that was like when I'd been
drinking alcohol oh that's interesting I
mean I think that I just have like so
much on my mind that I don't process
during the day because I'm like actively
trying to like fight out negative
thoughts in my brain do you know what I
mean yes I do not know what you mean
so I actually who could it be
I actually have little barks no I love
them he has something to say well I have
something to say I actually have my
first appointment for therapy next week
congratulations yeah thank you it's been
something I feel like once I start
talking like then a little
get out of my brain and I could finally
[ __ ] sleep that's good I'm proud of
you for going this has been these past
few months have been some of the most
mentally trying they I'm sorry the most
mentally trying I've never experienced
something like this in my whole life and
I feel like that's that for everyone yes
definitely any you have to self care
self love and you've got a ya gotta to
be like necessary steps I used to be one
of the people who thought like therapy
was for weak people I'm like I'm too
strong but like I'm not no but it's not
for weak people that actually takes a
really strong person to like recognize
that they could benefit from talking to
someone else
totally I think like where my
reservation is I feel like now I'm in a
therapy session I have like all these
thoughts in my brain that I'm like kind
of embarrassed of and like I don't want
the therapists like tell anyone like it
they're embarrassing well you know what
I've learned from mean culture it's that
like we all have the same thoughts and
the same weird thoughts and like
everything that you think or say that's
like weird someone else has thought the
same thing or something weirder you know
that's a very interesting observation
yeah I feel like I wouldn't be a good
therapist but I feel like it could be a
good life coach but I don't even have my
own life together so but I guess I know
like what steps that I could take yeah I
bet you could find a very a big amount
of life coaches who don't have their
lives together that's true and I feel
like you're just like setting yourself
up for people to be like well that's
like if you're a matchmaker you have to
married I don't think that's true cuz
when I think of later old-school
matchmakers you know like from the
shtetl it was always just like an older
woman in the community and I don't know
that she was always a married one like
in Fiddler on the Roof you know yeah
it's always what I think about when I
think of matchmakers okay are you ready
for oh I am normal and I think of Patti
Stanger I think of that first and then
I'm like okay she trademarked it but
like there's a whole matchmaking that
happened for centuries before her in
shuttles and cabooses ever there yes
exactly
okay but our next story is another sweet
one another like I guess just
piggybacking on with yesterday's story
Caitlyn Jenner's publicist is working
overtime this week because Kendall and
Kylie Jenner celibate pride
and their dad Caitlyn they say quote she
is our hero
so for Kendall and Kylie this transition
only brought them closer to their dad
Kendall said when my dad came out as
transgender our relationship grew she
could finally be honest with me we could
talk about deep emotions she was feeling
through that time growing up my dad was
not usually one to talk about her
feelings so that was a big step for us
Kendall says she's been a daddy's girl
her whole life and now their
relationship grows every day that is so
cute and Kylie had similar things to say
about her relationship with Caitlyn
quote my dad has always been an
inspiration to me from winning the gold
medal at the Olympics to getting her
pilot's license
however watching her live out her true
self has been the most inspiring of them
all the sisters agree quote she's our
hero wait that's actually really cute
and I guess it answers some of the
questions we had yesterday about where
the Kardashians landed in their
relationship with Caitlyn sounds like a
Gucci the Jenner girls always had
Caitlyn's back and I think they were the
most torn um where is the Kardashian
girls were always teen Kris but I think
ultimately everyone wanted what was best
for the Jenner girls and therefore
everyone has come together and when
everything about this family I just
think about no boo Malibu for some
reason yeah I feel the end and I've just
been seen like pictures on just yard and
stuff and they're really like inspiring
we're like Demi Lovato and her boyfriend
are leading no but Malibu like people
are go there's a chance I don't know I
don't know and then did you see the
other day like Kylie went to a club
Bootsy bellows who's me I saw it on
Daily Mail like she I guess her and her
she was with psy Kendall's friend I
think they like rented out the whole
club and like went to the club oh my god
like that is the level of wealth I
aspire to and that's exactly how I would
spend my [ __ ] money like rent out the
hottest club in town during quarantine
yeah oh my god I'm like so jealous that
how did I miss that I don't know it was
very low-key story I saw it on the other
mail snapchat I should go there more
often oh we were just talking about that
about I mean I don't have a snapchat
anymore cuz like it's not really like
the platform I like lit for anymore it
used to be but
when they launched that whole like
discover page with all these different
media outlets like it was a show
unnecessary
except the Daily Mail story it's just
filled with first of all fabulous
celebrity photos so if you're like a pop
culture enthusiast you'll get the best
paparazzi photos in all the land and
then they have like the weirdest stories
like cult family of 50 found in bunker
in Idaho like they have the weirdest
[ __ ]
this weirdest like science stories like
it's actually just a fabulous roundup of
what's going on in the world yes it very
much is I used to am shot from time to
time because I do like their camper
filter so I head over that way I'm I
don't if I've you know if spending so
much time on tick tock has taught me
anything it's said that the uses of our
generation are actually still using
snapchat quite frequently great I'm
happy for them know that I am yeah okay
ready for our next story
no why not cuz I have something to say
say it you should just let it out that's
the theme of this episode just let it
out okay well I was gonna talk about
this in therapy but I think I saw just
say it here today's episode is brought
to you by noon getting in shape doesn't
have to be about losing a specific
amount of weight or a magic number on
the scale it's about building healthier
habits and feeling better about yourself
if fitting into that favorite pair of
jeans is your goal great but there are
many reasons why you might want to
practice self-care and every person is
different because everyone's different
NUMA just to your lifestyle they teach
you the psychology behind the decisions
you make and then help you keep track of
everything from workouts to steps to
analyzing your diet and recommending
healthy recipes new also connects you
with a personally assigned goal
specialist and a community of other
numers show you all of the support you
need to empower change so if you want to
get in shape start feeling better I'm
there many reasons why you might want to
do that but some of them are could be
better self-care feeling confident your
clothing having more energy or just
having an overall glow the great thing
about name is that you can integrate it
in your life so you trust yourself to
make better choices Noom is not a diet
is it is a healthy and easy to stick to
way of life it is the habit changing
solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses
they teach you why you do the things you
do and then empowers you with the tools
you need to break bad habits and replace
them with better ones we're all strapped
for time so new masks you to commit to
just 10 minutes a day for yourself
you're human if you go off track there's
no shaming just tips to help you get
back on track tomorrow you don't have to
change it all in one day small steps
make big progress sign up for your trial
today at noon calm / toast that's n o om
dot-com / toast what do you have to lose
visit neucom / toast to start your trial
today that's n oom calm / toast love it
sign on get your mind and your body
right I actually think that my
quarantine like should be sponsored by
noon because it has been the best tool
for me to just I don't have such lofty
goals I just like want to maintain some
sort of balance in my life and this very
unbalanced time and new has been a great
aid in doing that and there are a lot of
toasters we've had a lot of success with
me I think there's even a Facebook group
yes okay next story is just perfect and
in this vein lizzo is slamming body
shame hers in her new workout tik-tok
saying quote I am beautiful
the only ideal body type for Liz o is
her own the 32 year old singer posted a
video of her workout regimen - tik-tok
Tuesday telling online body chambers
that there's more than to one's health
then whose then what's featured on the
outside so she posted a montage of her
working out and over it her saying hey
so I've been working out consistently
for the last five years and it may come
as a surprise to some of y'all that I'm
not working out to have your ideal body
type I'm working out to have my ideal
body type and you know what type that is
none of your [ __ ] business she said
in the voice-over of the clip if you're
not a fat Shamer
keep scrolling okay now that all the fat
chambers are here and she continued to
say I'm beautiful I am strong I do my
job and I stay on my job I actually saw
this - tik-tok I'm in the brief time I
spend on tik-tok and I just absolutely
loved it yeah you know what um I have
like I said been spending so much time
on tik-tok and lizzo is just a fabulous
creator like she's on all the trends
like she do that's with her fans like
she's really really good at it but just
in my time perusing tick tock I
can't tell you how many fat phobic you
like videos I see and so many of them
are about Liz oh it's like so
disrespectful I wish that tick-tock
would just like implement more like
regulations just to like it's it's
weirdly this platform where young people
are so creative and like a lot of them
use it to come out like a lot of them
are using it in these like beautiful
creative ways and then some of them like
I see fat phobic [ __ ] once a day maybe
more times a day like I don't even know
why they're serving it to me like why am
I getting it why cuz I'm that but like
it's just they need to do a better job
because so many young people are on this
app and they're so influential that like
it's just really saying it's like
sending a bad message with how much fat
phobic content is on there like I can't
believe some of the [ __ ] I see yeah Wow
I haven't seen a lot of that but I
imagine that you spend more time there
so you've seen more um and that's that
ain't right that ain't right but good
for Liz o for first of all like standing
up to the haters and just doing it in a
fabulous wait like this is what we said
when we were talking about the BTS
stands coming for us like you're gonna
come for us like you got to be creative
and they call this irrelevant uglies
which I actually really liked so Liz oh
is now coming for her haters and she's
doing it in a fabulous creative funny
smart unique way and that's really all
we can ask for from our icons it's all
we can ask for and we're getting every
every bit of it
oh you know what we haven't spoken about
Taylor Swift on here in a while but I
really want to share something that I
saw okay yes please share we have not
spoken about her in a while and I'm and
I think that I remember there was that
week like I think it was maybe or am
like the Scooter Braun stuff where we
were talking about Taylor Swift every
single day I think people literally
stopped listening because they couldn't
take it those were the days okay so
there has been this like tumblr reddit
thread going around that's someone who
claims to be like super close to Taylor
like there's a big secret coming out I
can't and what she wrote was like I
can't say anymore this is Taylor special
moment not mine
stay alert in the coming weeks after it
happens the clue I gave will make
perfect sense and this is the clue the
traditional the traditional beliefs
customs and stories of a community
passed through the
generations by word of mouth that's the
clue now everyone had different um
things to like guess what this meant
nobody had my guess and I'm like almost
100 percent sure that I'm right so I
just wanted to put it on this podcast in
case that I'm right okay so that
different that definition the
traditional beliefs customs and stories
of a community passed through the
generations by word of mouth is like the
merriam-webster definition for folklore
which is irrelevant I just thought that
I would share I don't know what that
means
but that's that's relevant that seems
relevant
what's folklore the traditional okay yes
so I I really think and I couldn't
believe that nobody else thought this
that is pretty much like a word-for-word
description of dragged lead everything I
mean I think that she's gonna be on drag
race and you think that they would do
this much hype oh my god yeah the
Swifty's are like so dramatic okay what
am i t BG t BG people think maybe she's
pregnant like I don't know tbh he
explained to me how like drag is like
the only art form left that you can't go
to school for like it really needs to be
taught that's why everyone has like drag
mothers they like the same last name as
people they worked with or people they
met and it all the customs like the
makeup oh that is really passed through
by word of mouth because there is no
like school of drag so I just I thought
that I might be onto something anything
really that's a really great guess thank
you so I just wanted to put it on the
podcast like in case she ends and by the
way the new season of RuPaul all-stars
started last week so it's not so crazy I
have now I'm like really invested that's
a really interesting and good clue you
know usually we get like seven palm
trees and then we're told from later
that it didn't mean anything
like an engagement maybe a pregnancy I
don't think so I thought when you first
said that I thought maybe a book oh
where did snow so the girl who will
dance is not mean absolutely major is
going to happen shortly can't tell you
what it is but it'll be a shocker cruel
summer is not being released as a single
according to my sources wish it was
allowed to say more so I don't think
it's about music
I don't think it's about music either
but it does seem like it's something
really major and I don't know with a
guest spot on one episode of RuPaul's
Drag Race
it bounces so that was my only
trepidation it's like it's not that big
of a deal but to the Swifty's like
everything's a big deal every time you
see Taylor
yeah I agree Wow okay now I'm in this so
please keep me posted I always like I
need to close a circle on stuff like I
can't just leave these things open-ended
you know it'll like I'll wake up in the
middle of the night be like the
traditional folklore the traditional
customs beliefs and trevallies exactly
okay next story Bogues editor-in-chief
Anna Wintour has apologized to her staff
for not doing enough to elevate black
employees and models and for overseeing
spreads that may have been seen as quote
hurtful or intolerant over her 32 year
tenure at the glossy magazine vogue she
wrote a letter to her employees sort of
apologizing there has been a lot of
stuff happening within Conde Nast I just
saw last night that now former employees
are speaking up about their experiences
um the the editor-in-chief of bone
Appetit um is out there's an interim
editor at the moment but meanwhile
Harper's Bazaar has just appointed
Sameera Nasser to the editor in chief
the first woman of colour to hold the
prestigious title at the 153 year old
publication so that's some good news
with it's like 152 years too late but
that is good news we are moving forward
in terms of Conde Nast like honestly
vogue is like it's fabulous of course
but like it's also the pinnacle of like
exclusivity like the fashion industry
like is notoriously not exclusive to
people of color plus-sized people like
this doesn't shock me not honestly Shaw
inclusive sorry you said not exclusive
oh sorry it's the pinnacle no I said
it's a pinnacle of exclusivity yes and
then you said the fashion industry is
notoriously not exclusive to people I
said I think I said non-inclusive okay I
think this is being recorded so I think
I said what
all I'm saying is that this isn't
necessarily like the most shocking thing
I've ever heard but honestly the fact
that Anna Wintour is actually addressing
it that's what shocks me yes I I agree
it's I mean I think that she needed to
address it because there's a lot of
stuff within on like not just vogue but
within the company that is unacceptable
and so she wrote a very lengthy letter
that was an email that was sent around
to everyone where she says she quote
takes full responsibility for those
mistakes you know what I feel like her
time might be up soon yeah we say that
every time that we talk about her on
this show which isn't that frequently um
but you know what actually I just
downloaded Andre Leon Talley --zz book
and I remember seeing headlines but not
really reading articles cuz I didn't
know the backstory but like I think
there's Trump in a beer and so I'm gonna
read the book this weekend and I'll let
you know like what the tea is I don't
know why it is that like I dislike I
don't winter and I honestly like I know
nothing about fashion but I just like no
she's not good at her job I can't
explain it like I just know it in my
bones and I don't know I just think it's
time for like a new frontier like she's
just so old-school and is Meryl Streep's
character supposed to be her yeah yes
maybe that's why I just inherently don't
like her yeah The Devil Wears Prada
Young heard the devil but I actually
just watched that movie and it's been on
every single day they play it on E every
day for the last five years like but I
actually don't regard it as one of my
favorite movies it's definitely in the
genre of my favorite movies like that
kind of vibe but I was just watching and
it's really such a fabulous movie except
um what really frustrated me about the
movie and it's like you know when you
watch things with fresh guys like you
see whole new lies um one of the most
frustrating things of the movie it's
like her group of friends and her
boyfriend were just like so not
supportive of her career and like they
acted like she was just like selling out
when she was like just trying to get by
so she could do a year at this job and
then get a better job like she was she
was in like not entrepreneurship just
like I had hustle and she was a harsh
and she's ambitious yes and it's like
everyone like faulted her for that and
to be honest like that's the biggest
problem with
like her her group of friends were not
supportive and she they made her feel
guilty for having passion no end like
for leaning into the job that she did
have like yes this wasn't the job that
she wanted she's not a runway girl but
you know what she has to be here for a
while and she's gonna make the most of
it and embrace the workplace and they
just like made her feel like garbage and
I I didn't like that either yeah and
then I was telling you this oh I was on
FaceTime with you um the character who
plays like the writer for The New Yorker
that blonde guide Christian who like
follows her around art galleries and
like like takes her to eat falafel in
Paris like for my whole life like up
until maybe a year ago I thought that
that guy was Billy Bush they look so
similar I've never been like super
familiar with Billy Bush's work I just
know he's like curly and blonde and this
guy was curly in LA and I'm like oh how
cool the guy from Access Hollywood got a
starring role in a movie okay Billy Bush
is not blond I just want to say that
like he's wings under net mm-hmm he's a
brunette a hundred percent block just do
a quick Google
he's brunette for sure but you actually
touch on something quite poignant that
their facial structures like if you if
you buzz both of their heads twins okay
I just want to say like sometimes he's
brunette and sometimes he's blond he
definitely Iblees just his hair
sometimes Billy Bush okay let me look
images oh my god Claudia like that's
just not a blonde whatever I just I
can't believe that like it's like when I
was younger I used to really get
confused between Sandra Bullock and
Julia Roberts like to me they were never
in the same room at the same time like
they were just the same person and I
thought that all that confusion was
behind me until Billy Bush and the guy
from Devil Wears Prada know that
confusion catches up with us all the
time like we're constantly mixed up so
we kind of took a weird tangent but
basically Anna Wintour is terrible at
her job that's what I was trying to say
yeah okay ready for our fifth and final
story little interesting museum news Oh
a little Museum museum ooh yes I'm
I love museums my favorite an Avicii
Museum is opening in Stockholm in 2021 a
new museum dedicated to the life and
music of Avicii will open in Stockholm
Sweden next year for a press release en
bici experience will bring it to
visitors closer to the artists Avicii
and the person Tim Bergling the audience
will follow Tim's journey from a
reclusive music nerd to a celebrated
superstar from his boyhood room where
all the N to the LA studio where the
biggest hits were created on display at
the Museum will be a mix of memorabilia
and previously unseen photographs and
videos exhibits will also offer visitors
the chance to quote peer inside the
creative process and the many
collaborations behind the music when the
Adichie experience opens it will boast
previously unpublished early version of
Avicii's breakthrough hit levels as well
as troves of previously unreleased music
used to crack the 2019 posthumous album
Tim you know what's so funny is before
he like had his surname he was releasing
music under the name Tim Berg and I'll
literally never forget I never felt so
stupid in my life like I had found like
this when Avicii was popular like I had
found this like old house song on like
YouTube or something and I showed it to
Ben I'm like do you know the song by Tim
Berg and he's like that's a beachy and
I'd like literally felt so stupid but I
feel like not a lot of people know that
no not a lot of people know that I do
feel like I've heard that story before
but I still feel still feels like the
first time feels like the first time
haha you know what I'm curious if this
museums gonna have like a hallway
dedicated to the mysterious death of a
beachy you know because there are many
conspiracy theories there are many
conspiracy theories so you watch the
documentary about him it was so good I
feel like I care so much more about this
museum and a beachy and like the
incredible talent that he was because I
saw that documentary like it really gave
me perspective into understanding like
what a phenomenon he was but also what
he dealt with in his life and I like I
don't have plans to go to Stockholm
anytime soon but I would if this museum
we're in New York I would definitely go
to it yeah I mean when you think about
like though the arc of like music and
just like where we've come from in the
last like 20 years Avicii was like the
first person playing like beats on the
radio like now it's like popular every
song has like a beat break and like most
some songs don't even have lyrics it's
just beats but like he was really the
first person and I remember when I first
heard levels like it was so
revolutionary like it was just beats no
words like it was really like a
game-changer and the fact that they
played it on the radio was so crazy and
it totally changed the landscape of like
electronic and pop and like every type
of man forever ik yeah I agree the song
levels like just shifted where we were
going in terms of music and totally he
he's one of the greats
um his story is just kind of like tragic
and sad but I'm glad there's gonna be a
museum that will celebrate his life and
his like worry yeah I love this idea of
doing museums for for people I've not
really heard of this but now I'm just
like learning to think other major
celebrities or talents that I could like
use a museum from Anthony Bourdain Kobe
Bryant the Kardashians okay but they're
alive I know but like still that way
they can like have input yeah I guess I
mean it not everyone can do it like you
had to have accomplished so much like a
beach he had bands like from all over
the world like millions and millions
like this is actually gonna be a popular
tourist destination for Stockholm yeah
and now it's reminding me of the Taylor
Swift like reputation it wasn't a museum
but it was sort of set up like one yeah
and I went to that and it was great and
so I like this this idea yeah also the
Game of Thrones museum that was also a
pop-up was fabulous i sat on the Iron
Throne there's a picture somewhere yeah
fabulous so those are the past day
stories and I feel so that you needed to
know them okay well I have some TV I
want to recap but before we do today's
episode is brought to you by stamps comm
for all of our sakes we need to avoid
crowds any way we can right now but what
if you need to go to the post office
what if you need postage to send out
letters and packages
don't worry stamps comm is here to help
with Sam Stark on good print postage on
demand and skip the lines and crowds at
the post office plus you can eventually
save some money with discount so you
can't get at the post office and if that
wasn't enough Sam Starcom also offers
UPS services with discounts up to 62
percent and no UPS residential
surcharges Sam's comm brings all the
services of the US Postal Service right
to your computer in the safety and
comfort of your own home office or
anywhere else you're hunkering down
right now whether you're a small
business sending invoices or online
sellers shipping a product or you're
just working from home and need to mail
stuff stamps.com can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
just leave it in your mailbox
for your mail carrier schedule a free
pickup or drop it in the mailbox no
human contact is required it's that
simple and like we said with stamps comm
you get great discounts to 5 cents off
every first-class stamp and up step up
to 62 percent off shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer especially
now saving you time and money and
keeping you safe and he's crazy
unprecedented times right now our
listeners can get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
com click the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in toast
that's stamps comm and enter toast on
the microphone at the top of the page
stay safe my friends stamps calm Thank
You stamps thank you Sam Sam they are so
person into the situation right now
because when I walk down the street the
only place that has a line around the
block is the post office and people
trying to set now packages and with
Sam's calm like skip the lines send the
pack and by the way now at like UPS and
the post office there's only one person
allowed in at a time so like you have to
wait outside so if it's right like nilam
the lines are around the block torture
it's like the hottest club in town
okay so quickly I watch watch happens
like last night and they had Tamron Hall
and kandi Burruss talking like pop
culture but also you know the current
climate what's going on in the world and
there was actually a very very sweet
moment and everyone makes fun of candy
on real houses in Atlanta for crying but
all the time but she cried I'm watching
up inside and it was like so um like
everyone got choked up because she and
he was like they both have young kids
and they're like how do you explain like
what's going on you know to your kids
and like how do you teach him about
racism because this is something they're
you know sadly gonna face and kandi was
like you know we had such a
uncomfortable conversation and like a
sad one because their son um who's super
young like just dressed up as a cop for
career day and she was like trying to
explain to my son that like a cop did a
bad thing was like it was like his it's
like his whole belief system was like
shaken up and like everyone was just
like crying at this story I'm like
honestly I was crying to you like that
it was so sad and like just such a like
those are conversations that like black
families black parents have to have with
their children and it was it was
honestly just like heartbreaking Wow
yeah but it was a good episode actually
Tamron hall is like super cute and she's
like funny and it was a good episode
it was um they're doing watch Robins
live from home still and Andy's in the
Hamptons and ancien knows he feels like
a little checked out really yeah okay
well I have I haven't recorded so I will
watch but they didn't recap any TV did
they know and I was really watching to
see if Andy was gonna make a comment on
any of the Vanderpump rules drama or if
candy was gonna say something because on
that Instagram post on the Bravo TV
Instagram where they made the
announcement about the firing like so
many cast members from different shows
we're like leading comments I can
support of and candy was one of them so
I was just curious if like anyone was
gonna bring it up yeah but they didn't
they didn't okay well I guess that's why
Andy brought it up on his radio show um
this morning and I guess like and he's
just trying to like distance himself as
like the decision-maker he addresses it
then it's like it's on him to address
when it's not his decision and it's not
show and then it's on him to address
like every time something happens and
he's trying to let people know that that
he's not in that role so I guess that
makes sense
um where are you at on Potomac I'm in
the mic towards the end of season two
but they're about to go to Bermuda and
Giselle and Monique are still like at
odds I hope eventually one day like
right now their beef is just sort of
surface and I feel like they're just not
understanding each other from the get-go
but I think that they'll come together
it seems like that happened season 1 -
that always happens we're like a new
person comes in and someone's just like
standoffish Schwartz and just because
yeah and you know what like Giselle is
my favorite but I don't always like
agree with what she does or says she I
just like love her and I gravitated
towards her from the very beginning but
she can be like a little harsh I totally
agree and that's what I was saying when
I said i season one like she was my
favorite but pretty much every argument
she was in I just wasn't on her side you
know yeah which is weird cuz I'm used to
like standing for people who I just like
apologize for and agree with like
everything they say but with Giselle
it's like I just see past it like I just
love her you know who I happen to agree
with like a lot of the time on the show
so far
Ashley Darby I knew you were gonna say
that
I just think she is always making sense
whether she's like fighting with someone
or fighting with her husband she's just
constant word like talking about her
restaurant just ways okay you're gonna
feel dumb for saying that but okay but
up until this point like she's
constantly making sense okay well
actually got a DM from a toaster who
lives in Potomac saying that AHS is like
out of business it's been out of
business for a while I'm like it was a
desert desert land restaurant when it
was up in business which is sad because
honestly like I was ready to take a road
trip with you we're just too late okay
um I could see how that happens she just
did like this rebrand and she added like
some flat breads to the menu and people
were excited about it and I just I love
I think so far like my favorite person
on the show is Chris Samuels um he is
just please don't make say anything
there's no he's good are they okay just
tell me are they still together
yes okay good okay that's what I thought
um okay great I'm excited
I bet I love them as well um and you
know what I really I've never been to
like a housewife restaurant and actually
that's not true you and I had drinks
once at AOA which was that restaurant
Ramona pretended to be like an investor
in like ten years ago in Tribeca exactly
unfabulous bar and we've been to sur and
we've been to pump oh that's true I
forgot about that but I honestly really
want to go to olg candies restaurants
like they look so good and they all stay
open for the most part and they've been
open for quite some time and they she
keeps like opening new franchises so
like honestly it looks so good ooh okay
I'm excited I'm excited to keep watching
I have a lot of time today and I'm gonna
hopefully get into season three but
we'll see there's always like reunions
and yeah I have like nothing to watch I
found myself like literally all day
yesterday Lea laid in bed on my phone I
tried again to watch 13 reasons why and
I'm still on the first episode like it's
just so bad and you know what I think
it's because I just like everyone like
coal clay the main character like least
favorite human being like he's making
bad decisions and the whole show
revolves around him and I'm just done I
understand and that's that on that
that's that I'm mad I think that's all
anything else we wanted to talk about
today
no I think that that is all she wrote my
comedy special is available for
pre-order um you can find it on iTunes
Claudia sure I disgraced Queen it's also
on my Instagram I would really
appreciate it
and that's all we got thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the one a morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcasts anywhere
podcasts can be found Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio iHeartRadio
cashbox all the places whoever you
listen to podcasts find us the morning
shows and leave if I starve you about a
beautiful stunning inspire we are we
love you guys very very much thank you
so much for listening and we will see
you tomorrow for our final show of the
week bye